I like it I like it I don't had I'm not
mad at it wow I've been to a Taco Bell
but I've never eaten from Taco Bell I am
from Texas originally so I never had
Taco Bell because like why would I have
Taco Bell when I have perfectly good Tex
Mex all around my parents didn't let me
eat Taco Bell growing up and then by the
time I got old and I still hadn't had it
I just kind of was like why start now
oh it's a taco this looks like a taco
that they would service in school has a
very strong smell it does it's not a bad
smell ready for this cheers yes
[Music]
it's not bad it's actually really good
mm-hmm if this was a blind taste test
I wouldn't think this was talking about
it's very tightly wrapped look at how
neat that is you need to get that's only
just a Chia fight you know I have been I
think the beans are actually really good
the tortilla per bean / cheese ratio is
off you know we'll be good
avocados we're hot sauce this one looks
spicy great yeah this is the Dorito
shell taco I've always thought about
trying this
it looks radioactive it doesn't taste as
Dorito like no as I expected it I
thought the holding on Taco Bell knows
that everything was like spicy and
inspiring that so I kind of thought that
this would be that if I were inebriated
this would be a 10 yeah Victorine maybe
well I'm no longer a Taco Bell virgin so
that's that it was not the tex-mex of
Texas but it was very decent I think my
eyes have been opened I don't think this
is going to be a regular part of my
weekly eating routine but I think if I
was hungry and all there was was a Taco
Bell I know what I would order now and I
wouldn't be afraid to go inside yeah I'm
glad that I got this checked off my
bucket list I don't judge people anymore
who go but I'd know I'm like used to vex
I heard from my friends that when you're
high you know this is like the best food
to get and you know not that I you know
consume these legal drugs but
I heard out you'll be really good